what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg is here john how's
your day going i am just on cloud nine
today that's amazing to hear we have
some insane news i just did not expect
now this news is crazy it is wild you
can leave a like i would love if you
could leave that like
but the real crazy news is this
john
discovered this story
before i did
and all the years it's really okay i've
been waiting for you now finally don't
think find the stories and find the
trailer you you did it john i'm just
here you literally before i did it i
know what the audience is you're growing
up you're finally doing it that's right
man you're finally doing it after years
and years i took it to heart and i was
like today's the day
today is the day this the real rejects
gonna change forever after today guys
we've carved a new path
we're gonna be even more on top of it
now that both of us are on top
we're gonna break the news before it's
out ten minutes before you're gonna be
like damn they were right all along oh
my god okay here's what's going on john
why don't you what's what's the report
what's that
other news today it has been officially
confirmed that batfleck ben affleck's
batman is returning for aquaman 2. you
want to know how official it is who's
the one who confirmed this piece of
information
oh goodness
who was the specific one i read it on so
many different places
you came jason that's right
his instagram always throws me because
it's called pride of gypsies and then i
keep having to remember it was a bigger
confirmation than jason moa
going on
my god you were this close johnny you
had almost all of us
this is the humbling you see i saw the
profile pic and i saw the title of his
thing and i and i got faked out by all
the the words well let okay let me pull
it up pearson's not alone it's not
loading up hold on
i saw the picture of them together i
should have just assumed it was the gram
of the of the mamoa all right so here he
is he's got a photo posing with a very
in shape batflick here's what his
caption john
let me redeem myself by breaking yours
drop the phone
john please this is big news i am so
nervous this is big news guys listen
reunited my man bruce and arthur love
you and miss you ben warner brother
studio tours just explored the backlot
all right busted on set all great things
coming aquaman 2 all my aloha j it's a
bit of a word salad of a caption yeah
but they look like they're having the
best time they got some amazing photos
together and they got busted on it this
is they got busted this is hilarious
news and i'm so happy that ben affleck
the man who seemed we've done videos
here where we're like guys look
this guy wants to know what to do with
this letter
let that flick go and i'm like look what
[ __ ] storm you've just caused for
yourself ben affleck make the batflick
movie i say hashtag make the batfleck
movie what's wild about this and um
there might be some minor spoilers here
my very minor there were some test
screenings for aquaman too and i don't
know like the plot details whatsoever
other than the fact that you know walter
hamada was on trial at the amber herd
thingy magic and he was saying that it's
supposed to be like a buddy movie
between him and patrick wilson that's
about all i know in terms of plot we
know that michael keaton's batman is
going to be in the flash and is going to
be a very central figure in that film
and that's supposed to be ben affleck's
last movie as the flash and the timeline
still lines up because i might be wrong
about this but i believe it was supposed
to be the flash and then aquaman and
then the release dates changed i wonder
why
only vfx artists but i can't think of
anything else that remember
the reports were saying that you know in
some test screenings that it was
actually michael keaton's batman who was
supposed to be in this the reason i'm
saying it's minor spoiler because it
doesn't look like that's gonna be the
case anymore
because i think they would have to just
because of continuity and lining [ __ ] up
and the fact that it seems that after
whatever hodgepodge the flash multiverse
creates for our characters in the dc
extended universe that that's when we
would have michael keaton's batman you
know back as like the main batman or
something like that right we don't
really know what the hell they're doing
but yeah but if that's the direction it
seems like it's going so to not confuse
you know audiences with timeline
continuity and like does aquaman take
place after the flash or before the
flash i imagine that's why they you know
had to bring back ben affleck for this
so that way you know it still lines up
timeline wise because aquaman's coming
out first before the flash movie comes
out that's just my main theory as to why
they would want to bring him back when
there was already reports coming out
about michael keaton appearing in
aquaman the lost kingdom yeah one
that'll be really cool because you know
in justice league get to work really
hard to get arthur on board in the first
place sure build on top of that and i
mean that actually that makes a whole
ton of sense i think maybe that will
give us the actual send off for uh you
know ben affleck's bruce wayne that
maybe we were hoping for that you know
we wanted to see a little bit more after
justice league now we'll get that you
know it's because
him and jlo are buying billion dollar
homes right now hey guys listen
i know i was exhausted but i got some
things to pay for
and uh can we make this happen can we
take notaro me into this movie and now
that he's married they're married now
right they got like secretly married
something like that secretly eloped i
think it's all jlo's work i'm pretty
sure she was like she talked to the
studio i'm a big snyder verse fan
you need to make that happen honey you
need to make it happen she cut him into
the shazam 2 trailer and got him
recasting that even makes more sense why
they would show him in the shazam
trailer now yeah absolutely we're take
we're really embracing the last vestiges
of the snyder verse as we head towards
the reset with the flat instead of doing
what they did with superman lately which
is like hide him and mask him which i
thought they might do for the [ __ ]
for referencing him they actually showed
him up front and center so that's why
they can't do it twice because they had
to do that to ezra miller yeah he had to
cut off ezra miller's you know body at
the same time just a little bit but you
know the thing that i am i am i'm
waiting now is because you know i you
get the impression you know you got like
zack snyder who clearly relishes and
revels in the fact that people are
always saying restore the snyder verse
make it happen zack snyder's two come on
come on dc you know like you got that
side the perception that it would at
least
on a lot of our ends you know admittedly
mine and maybe still
like i don't know now he doesn't want
anything to do with this anymore let it
go he's just reignited the flames you
know now it's going to lead to all kinds
of theories and speculation about will
we try to get that ben affleck hbo max
show will we try to get that batfleck
movie what if the response to him being
in aquaman 2 and the flash is so
grandiose and people love it so much
that they're like we got to get this
baffling keep going now that's the main
thing i think that uh we're going to be
looking forward to now
batman just overshadowing the upcoming
dc movies as we go hey as long as it's
not a controversy i think they'll take
it all right guys thank you so much for
being here what do you think about this
news leave your thoughts down below you
can subscribe click that notification
bell leave a like last but not least
daniel gallacher you are truly the
batman
of this channel because you know why
you're loud in scotland where they shot
much of the batman and i think it would
be very cool to see you do a batman
cosplay and then i will dress up as
aquaman fly out to scotland we can find
like a cool cliff to stand on and then
we can take a photo shoot like a
tasteful semi-erotic photo shoot of us
doing a slash fick of when uh you know
bruce wayne goes to recruit arthur curry
i think it would be great uh and i'm
just itching to hear you call me your
man so uh let's do that even though
that's aquaman's line i'll greet you
with that but you understand what i mean
anyway
love you dan does anyone call you dan
danny danny boy that's irish i gotta
edit this cool
[Music]